Hi ihr Lieben! Heute gibt's ein ganz besonderes Rezept,
wir machen nämlich einen Wolkenkuchen!
Ich glaube der Strawberry Cloud Cake ist bekannter in Amerika als in Deutschland,
aber es wird mal Zeit, dass wir den hier fleißig nachmachen.
Und zwar ist das ein Kuchen, der wirklich wie Erdbeerwolken schmeckt, also extrem leicht!
Und das Ganze ist No Bake, das heißt wir tun den gleich einfach in die Tiefkühltruhe
und dann ist er auch schon fertig, also super schnell gezaubert!
Ich mach jetzt hier erstmal den No Bake Boden
und dafür hab ich hier einmal Butterkekse - ich geb hier alles gleich in meinen Mixer -
also Butterkekse, dann hab ich Haferflocken, Kokosraspeln und weiche Butter,
bzw. flüssige Butter, die habe ich aber leicht abkühlen lassen.
So jetzt gebt ihr den Keksboden ganz einfach in eine Springform mit 26cm Durchmesser,
unten drunter gern ein Backpapier legen und richtig schön fest andrücken!
Das kommt jetzt erstmal zur Seite und wir machen jetzt die leckere Wolkenfüllung,
die ist wirklich extrem lecker!
Und ich zeig euch jetzt hier die Zutaten, ich hab hier einmal Erdbeeren,
- ihr nehmt gerne zur Erdbeersaison auch frische Erdbeeren - ich hab jetzt hier die TIefkühlvariante,
und hab sie schön auftauen lassen und abtropfen lassen.
Dann hab ich hier natürlich Zucker für die Süße,
für den Geschmack ganz, ganz wichtig: Vanilleextrakt, verlink ich euch in die Infobox
und einen Spritzer Zitronensaft.
Und dann haben wir eine Zutat, da werdet ihr bestimmt ganz viel in die Kommentare schreiben:
wir haben nämlich Eier, besser gesagt Eiweiß.
Wir brauchen hier rohes Eiweiß. Wenn das Ei mega frisch ist, ist es natürlich auch gar kein Problem.
Es sei denn ihr seid jetzt schwanger oder habt eine Allergie, dann müsst ihr das Rezept skippen.
Oder wenn ihr das nicht möchtet, dann hab ich leider keine Alternative für euch,
weil wir das Ganze natürlich gleich in die Tiefkühltruhe legen.
Und ihr werdet's nicht bereuen, es schmeckt extrem fluffig und lecker!
Und ich werd jetzt erstmal die Eier trennen - das ist ganz wichtig, dass ihr die sauber trennt
und das Eigelb nehm ich später für Rührei oder für Lemon Curd,
da gibt's ja auch tausend Möglichkeiten!
So, der nächste Step ist jetzt total einfach
wir geben zum Eiweiß wenn ihr möchtet eine Prise Salz, die hebt den süßen Geschmack.
Dann natürlich Zucker, außerdem Zitronensaft, Vanilleextrakt und die Erdbeeren,
die jetzt bestenfalls total weich sind weil sie eben auf Zimmertemperatur sind.
Und danach mixen wir das Ganze, bzw. währenddessen, maximale Stufe, 5min.
Ihr werdet erst so nach 2-3min denken: "Hä, was ist das denn? Das wird ja gar nicht steif!"
Aber nach 5min: Bam! Richtig fluffig!
Und ich zeig euch das Ergebnis jetzt nochmal aus der Nähe.
Das ist der Inbegriff von Fluffigkeit!
Und diese Masse schmeckt genau so, wie sie aussieht. Sie schmeckt genau so, wie sie aussieht!
Total locker-leicht!
(H: Würd am liebsten da reinspringen!)
Ich auch! Ich will mir daraus am liebsten so ne Gesichtsmaske machen!
So toll sieht das aus!
(H: Jetzt übertreibst du aber!)
So richtige Fantasien mit dieser Masse!
So, jetzt geben wir das einfach auf den Keksboden, verteilen das
und dann - ihr glaubt's kaum - aber dann sind wir eigentlich schon fertig.
Richtig krass wie schnell das jetzt ging, ne?
(H: Echt jetzt?)
Ja! Heftig, ne?
(H: Krass!)
Und jetzt hab ich die Creme in meine Springform gegeben und oben nicht glatt gestrichen,
sondern halt wolkenmäßig so ein bisschen unregelmäßig.
Ich persönlich find das schöner, ihr könnt natürlich machen was ihr Zuhause gerne machen möchtet.
Aber denkt dran: Oben drüber kommt gleich noch eine leckere Erdbeersoße.
Die zeig ich euch jetzt im Schnelldurchlauf weil die echt easy ist.
Ihr nehmt einfach tiefgekühlte Erdbeeren, müsst ihr gar nicht auftauen lassen
- oder frische wenn ihr Saison habt - und dann gebt ihr da ein bisschen Zucker mit dazu,
einmal aufkochen lassen, gerne nochmal durch ein Sieb geben, damit ihr die Klümpchen nicht drin habt
und dann habt ihr ne fertige Erdbeersoße! So einfach geht das, lasst sie einfach abkühlen
und dann könnt ihr euch die im Kühlschrank aufbewahren.
Die hier kommt jetzt übrigens in die Tiefkühltruhe für 8h.
Seid mir da nicht böse, aber 8h ist wirklich die Zeit, die diese geniale Torte jetzt braucht.
Und ihr könnt das natürlich am Vortag vorbereiten.
Und in der Kühltruhe hält sie sich bis zu 6 Wochen.
Also ihr habt immer was da wenn Besuch da ist oder wenn ihr selber mal Lust drauf habt,
könnt ihr euch da immer ein Stück von abmachen.
Lasst das dann ungefähr ½h auf Zimmertemperatur stehen,
dann wird der Keksboden auch nochmal schön weich und nicht so fest.
Und die Konsistenz ist einfach extrem lecker!
Macht diese Torte unbedingt nach! Ich freu mich über eure Fotos,
ich freu mich wenn ihr diesem Video ein Däumchen nach oben da lasst, wenn es euch gefallen hat.
Ansonsten abonniert doch meinen Kanal kostenlos, dann verpasst ihr hier auch solche genialen Rezepte
wie dieses nicht mehr!
Und dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten Rezept!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!